the the the day's been running on time
and we're going to try to do the same my
name is Paul Yaak I'd like to welcome
you and this is the the last sprint into
the afternoon so we've got a great panel
put together we're going to focus on med
tech and as you can tell we have some
innovators who are are of a vintage that
they're out there doing this in the in
the first years after launching from
from from Stanford and what we want to
hear is kind of their perspectives
things are changing so radically as you
all know as we've been hearing about
today and we're going to get some in the
trenches perspectives about what's going
on the bios of our panelists are in your
programs but I want to just briefly
introduce each of them so on the far
left is Darin Hyde who's a principal
with Aberdare Darin has a MBA from
Stanford who's a be from Princeton did
medical school training work for
Medtronic for a number of years next to
him is mo Cowell who's recently taken a
new job as executive vice president
chief strategy officer for West wireless
technologies he'll tell us about that
but a new initiative down in San Diego
focusing on technology advance and cost
savings through wireless technologies
next to him is Darren Buxbaum who's CEO
and founder of hourglass technologies
company in the obesity space Darren's
and engineer economist from Duke who
also got his MBA from Stanford and to my
immediate left is Sudha Kumar Judy did
his undergraduate and his MD at Harvard
residency at Columbia cardiology
fellowship at UCSF was a by design
fellow and he founded AI rhythm
technologies where he is still the chief
medical officer
he's also active with the by design
program as a global fellowship director
soap
we would really love to have your
questions and input what I'd like to do
to kind of prime the pump is to find out
from each of these folks kind of the the
one key thing that that the most
important thing that they've experienced
that they didn't anticipate at all
coming out of their training program
this and they may need to tell us a
little bit more about the context of
their of their company to answer this
but okay let me start with you and and
we're going to go rapid fire so your
responsibility is to set the pace of
going quickly with this answer sure
thanks Paul thanks for everyone staying
through the afternoon to hear us so I
think I'll just give you a little brief
background on the company so you know
kind of the space I'm a cardiologist
cardiac electrophysiologist by training
so I deal with abnormal heart rhythms as
a as a bio design fellow we focus on the
unmet the field of electrophysiology an
arrhythmia care to try to understand
what our unmet needs long story short we
realized that there was an unmet need in
diagnosing people not by specialists but
at the primary care emergency room level
you've heard a lot about that today we
couldn't have anticipated it but we were
thinking ACO models even before there
was one but long story long as short of
it is that we developed or we started
the idea of a simple single-use
long-term disposable cardiac monitor
that could be placed in those settings
so that with one test the patient could
get diagnosed and one of our
requirements was really driving the cost
down so it was really at the cost of a
blood test so I decided to take the
company forward after I finished the
Biodesign fellowship really spent a lot
of time learning about what it means to
be able to articulate a value
proposition and really understand why
this need I really wanted to have the
idea killed if I could because I was
giving up practicing being a practicing
physician so I really wanted to see that
this was going to go somewhere and
you'll see why at the end of what I'm
going to say why all these elements are
important right now we're for years now
you know fast forward we're 130
employees we
we're selling our product widely across
the US we should hit our 10,000th device
at the end of this month and hopefully
do 20 or 30 thousand this year you know
and we what we're really seeing is Todd
and a lot of other people that you've
heard today have really seen what we're
doing is a different type of model in
terms of trying to focus on not just the
unmet need but unmet need in a business
innovation business model sense we
realize that specialists see oftentimes
patients they don't need to see and
oftentimes getting to a specialist as a
problem really focusing on getting
devices down to primary care level but
understanding how primary care in
emergency rooms physicians practice and
the cost constraints in the healthcare
system has been really really an
important element of our success in the
sense that when we're down in the low
$100 range for a device that records for
a long period of time that's easy for
patients to use we use cloud computing
to do all our algorithm analysis so
we're really scalable and more
importantly from the government
standpoint we've done this all in the US
that we've created 130 US jobs when you
put all that together you can see that
value and innovation don't necessarily
go are not antithetical to one other
they can they can actually survive and
coexist and represent solutions to good
opportunities so that's just a
high-level background and I left a lot
of things out in interest of time but
three things I think I've learned that
are important for anybody thinking about
starting companies so one is know your
limitations know what you're good at
which you're not good at I'm a physician
I think I'm reasonably smart but I don't
know everything
putting CEO after my name's mate would
make no sense to an investor
understanding the unmet need understand
clinical understand how to develop
something from a research standpoint
clinical standpoint yes so when I
started out one of the first things I
did was try to understand this is what I
can do this is what I can't do but can I
attract people who could fill in those
gaps
second thing understand the risk of your
project people always get in a lot of
the fellows have heard me say this
people always think that developing a
prototypes the most important sometimes
it is sometimes it's not in my case I
don't think anyone didn't think that we
could develop the device who's really
how do you change a paradigm of
delivering healthcare in the US that's
business execution so if you understand
your limitations and you understand what
the risk is my risk was really how do
you secure some IP and more important to
protect what we're going to do but also
more importantly how do I track someone
with industry
perience who can help fill in that void
so my first hire or the person who came
on board when I started the company is
the CEO who's still the CEO but multiple
years experience in cardiac rhythm
monitoring at different companies so
understood that landscape and then three
understand macroeconomic trends you've
heard it around all day today about the
issues of business model innovation that
value is now going to become a
requirement it's not just a nice to have
you know not just develop a cool
technology and later on figure out how
to pay for it you actually have to think
about how are you going to get paid for
it from the beginning so it's not just
you know we didn't talk about such a
regulatory risk because in our case it
wasn't as big a risk but understanding
these factors of where healthcare was
going obviously we couldn't have
predicted that Obama was elected we
couldn't predicted the Affordable Care
Act but there were trends already going
in that direction so having as a
requirement lowering the cost of
healthcare in fundamentally solving the
need was really important so if you take
those things understand the big picture
so that your need really is going to be
supportable by what investors are
looking at understand your risks so you
know what things you can address and
what you can't and then understanding
yourself to understand can you meet
those challenges because and if they
don't all align doesn't mean it's not a
good idea doesn't mean it's not a good
deed it just may not be the right time
for you to solve that problem so those
are the kinds of things I learned so far
that's greater than it and I'm gonna ask
you to keep track if you have a question
for the specific speaker we're going to
go through these kind of preliminary
comments first and then and then open it
up and Darren and in some sense it must
make you cringe to hear that regulatory
is not a particular issue from O'Dea but
but so our last technology is we're
developing a medical device in the
obesity space currently the only
effective treatments for patients who
are morbidly obese over a hundred pounds
overweight are invasive surgery is like
gastric bypass and gastric banding
surgeries those they're very effective
but of course they're invasive they take
place in an expensive operating room and
they carry you know multiple
complications so what we're doing at
hourglass technologies is we're taking
we're making these procedures much
less invasive we've converted the them
to a fully transferable procedure so
there are absolutely no incisions so
it's an incision free procedure that
will dramatically reduce the
complication rates and also make it a
much more cost effective procedure which
as we've heard throughout the day is
very much on the minds of every country
in the world and coming to the coming to
the US as well so just a little bit
about the company itself
we're a 15-person company as Paul was
alluding to this is a class 3 PMA you
know changed the world kind of device
and that brings up a lot of you know
regulatory a lot of regulatory hurdles
along the way we've raised 11 million
dollars to dates and we've been able to
partner with great partners including
Johnson Johnson maverick capital and an
XE capital and and that'll kind of tie
in to kind of my learnings along the way
so a big learning for me early on was I
had no idea how difficult it was good it
was going to be to raise funding you
know I thought here you are you know
obesity you know you can look at the
cover of Time magazine you can look
anywhere it's a really big issue in in
health care now
it's an extremely crabbit space before I
walked into it there are lots of great
entrepreneurs and great companies
working there and what's and who they
allude to it you know you have to
understand the risk that you're getting
into and for us what we realize is we
need to really separate the risks out
and it wasn't about okay just getting a
device that would work in patients it
was going much more fundamental and
saying well what are the issues that
people are having
and it was the biology it was the fact
that the stomach is an incredible organ
but it's very difficult to actually
control the stomach and so we were able
to
they split our entire system in two
parts and instead of coming up with a
full-fledged prototype we were able to
literally build a small device for $10
on my kitchen table and implant that in
some preclinical models and and show
that look this is this has a lot of
promise and use that as a leverage point
to raise the capital to move the company
forward but it really took you know
division of risk to be able to move the
needle with investors another another
area that I never anticipated was the
type of funding sources this is a
obesity and because it's a class three
PMA device it's going to take a lot of
capital to get this project to market
some of our competitors have spent
almost ninety million dollars and and
still never quite made it to market and
so it's forced us to look at alternative
funding sources so rather than going a
very traditional VC route you know we've
partnered with strategics with hedge
funds and you know really had to look at
this in a very different way much
because traditional venture has been
shying Arats trying away from really
early stage you know preclinical class
at class three you know high regulatory
risk devices so you know just keeping
the company alive to make sure that we
can help treat our first patients that
has certainly been been an eye-opening
experience but it's been a very
rewarding experience and we can't wait
to treat our first patient very soon so
interesting juxtaposition you have two
different models something where you
want up in really a cost-saving you know
a little bit of a new space and aligned
with what we're hearing about today
Darren in some sense you're a classic
strategy of taking an invasive procedure
making it less invasive in your case
considerably less invasive but different
funding strategies you had to invent
your funding strategies I suspect to
want to circle back on that and
a minute but mo you're coming at this
from from a really different perspective
and and mo I didn't mention you'll see
in the bio spend time at the FCC looking
at kind of macro issues of cost and
connectedness and value so tell us where
you're at and how you got to west so
after school so MD by background er guy
then ended up in venture capital dabbled
a billion devices IT services as well as
biotech and then policy background way
back in the day and then they decided to
jump on the whole health reform wagon
and then build the first healthcare team
at the FCC and I think Tom's car park
actually summed it up very well this
morning that health reforms a lot more
than just adding 30 million more people
into the system is actually how do we
change the delivery mechanism the
incentive mechanism and then how this
technology empower this and then I ended
up at the West Wireless Health Institute
we are essentially start up an 18-month
old Institute based in La Jolla we have
a couple of different functions we have
an investment fund we have have now
around 25 engineers we can cube eight
technologies we spin them out and we do
a range of policy issues as well and
everything's around the cost reduction
thesis so not too dissimilar to some of
the things I thought I was saying and I
was asked to talk about some of my
shared experiences or learnings I think
the main thing I've learned I've had
most success in my career when I focused
on and I've been lucky in some respects
focusing on high-growth areas and being
an early person within that space and
I'll give you some stories around that
at one point I was looking at
opportunities and medical device
startups and although I haven't
practiced in a long time clinically and
I have done Business School I had
business experience I was told I was
still a clinical person and had to focus
on junior clinical roles my friend in
the front and the front rows laughing at
me and then the week after I was
interviewing at an executive position
within an online healthcare delivery
platform so I think the law of supply
and AM and demand really also applied to
how you think about your career the
first guys who work for Google there was
no internet company for you to get
experience in medical devices biopharma
to an extent is a 20 year old industry
so
the skillsets and the experiences always
increases time goes on the first md's
working at Genentech had just an MD now
is MD PhD residency so I think that's
the thing I've learned the most by by
trying to pick high-growth areas and
being an early person to help shape it
has helped me in better stead Darrin so
so you're responsible for funding all of
these people out here settled your
perspectives yeah
so I work at avid air ventures fresh out
of doctor yox fabulous bio design class
and and the GSB here we do early-stage
device investing biotech investing
Wireless health investing hopefully here
in the new future in the near future and
I would just say that in my five years
already I feel like I've seen a lot
because things were working great when I
came in 2006 everything's sort of on the
path you know your your products working
you're hiring good people things are
looking great and then all of a sudden
things that are completely out of your
control when you make the investment
might have a really big impact on how
things go so the thing I learned the
most is that you can do all the upfront
work and figure out where the risks are
gonna be and and that everything you can
and that might not really have that much
of an impact on what happens down the
line so what we've tried to do is stay
out in front like like most said and I
think that area he's landed and it's
really interesting and then find great
people like Darren a new day down here
who are able to be nimble in difficult
times and be resourceful like Taryn has
been in difficult times that find their
way to success even when things are
harder than they might have seemed at
the beginning so let's do start giving
questions and and let me focus you too I
see a fair number of young people if I
may say so in the audience and if you if
you have career oriented questions the
other things we're going to go on and
talk about am really curious to hear
what what each of these folks is doing
with with a global strategy I want to
get to that and then
in the spirit of the day from each of
their perspectives kind of where things
are going where how they how they're
seen around the corners but but anything
career-wise Lind should we use the mic
so can we can we holler out are you okay
with that use the mics I thought that
might be the answer all right
so question I'm gonna pick on Moshe I'm
gonna pick on you okay and I'm let me
ask if you wouldn't mind going to the
mic so most you as many of you know also
is you know could well be up here as a
as one of the founder CEOs of a really
rocking company but if we put you on the
spot what what didn't you know about
getting into the career at when you were
here as a MBA what what what kind of
piece of advice would you give I guess
the the area with regards to which I was
most naive is that I thought that with
respect to all the government
interaction was being right and making
sense would be sufficient our value
proposition was quite similar to to us
we basically looked at something which
was which was one of the largest vme or
medical equipment spend items for the
agency and said we could eliminate
almost half of this cost immediately and
we thought that would suffice and you
know three years later it is not it's
clearly not not not sufficient and and
that's an area where I feel you know
where especially someone early on needs
to enhance its understanding on what it
would really take to galvanize a
government agency into an action even if
the action is beneficial to it it often
requires more than a good reasonable
rational yeah okay yeah I was gonna say
I think one of the things that Moshe hit
on that is an important thing to think
about in terms of when you lay out your
plan that is the cost it really takes to
understand reimbursement I think both he
and I are on the
same page in terms of one of the biggest
problems with the health care system and
innovation today is that you can go
through the entire FDA process and have
a device that's deemed safe by the US
government but payers particularly CMS
and then private payers will wait for
you to underwrite usage of a device
clinically shown option show trials to
then pay you even though at the end of
the day particularly again in my case if
you take into account the value that
could benefit them it's not a it's not a
justifiable or rational marketplace at
all and there's no risk sharing so I
think one of the other things you asked
Paul about a global sense from what we
do on the Indian and Singapore side it's
clear that today other countries can
develop products just as good as the
ones that have been developed here but
they've been doing so always with an eye
towards lower cost so at some point in
the at some point healthcare payers or
healthcare entities if I have a stent
from India that's just as good and it's
just as safe and it's ten from both
scientific or Medtronic here and I have
to make and once half the price
but equally effective I know which I'm
going to pay cuz it's a rational
decision so if the US government wants
that really think about innovating jobs
they have to address questions at motion
I have both provided them how do you
risk share with us I mean if we meet
milestones just like VCS want us to meet
milestones for regulatory why can't
there be reimbursement milestones such
that we prove to you in the next year
and we'll cost share for this if we hit
it you pay us some more you hit it we
pay some more until some agreed upon and
if we don't and we haven't proved that
we're of equal or superior not even
equal maybe superior outcome maybe we
don't deserve to be in the marketplace
so that's a that's something that
companies will have to look at do they
really want to do that and it goes back
to kind of things that were said earlier
that if you really have a much better or
after manual said yesterday if you
really have a much better technology
don't worry about in the payment will
come if you really are going to deliver
better outcomes but I think this whole
issue of innovative small companies
raising tens and tens of millions of
dollars after developing a working
product that's regulated and cleared is
somewhat crazy aunt is definitely in an
issue with the spurring innovation or
you need to think about that because
that's still going to be a reality for
the next
years so let's try to drill down on this
a little bit Todd Park in one of the
lunch break out sessions was saying look
it's clear you have to go to the
emerging accountable care organizations
and sell your new technology to them
okay
you're so you're out there trying to do
this is there any there to go to
surprisingly I mean you know
surprisingly even big payers today the
United others are seeing that they need
to embrace it so while there are still
some conservative private payers who
don't recognize the value a lot of other
ones are actually taking a look and
trying to look at data and trying to
figure out how do we promote this to our
beneficiaries but again we're at the
bleeding edge with the front edge of
this so what really happens and again
you saw Todd I mean he's as enthusiastic
as you'll get maybe for a nice Chopra
but those two guys are really trying to
figure out ways of doing something but
again they're working with the
government and one thing I like saying
is the speed of a startup is not the
speed of government you'll never match
each other and unfortunate thing for us
is that that means burn I mean so what
does it look like though I'm trying to
get a sense as much as you can tell us
for you oh sure are you getting
penetration yes so so for instance you
know we're kind of in a hybrid mode
because we can exist we one of my
requirements our requirements was we
want to go out into the marketplace with
any at least accessible to some code
it's much less than what we want but
something and we designed to that so
we're okay and obviously as we're
proving value we have Palo Alto DA's our
third biggest customer in the country
and they're paying they're praying the
price of the value of the test because
it's much less than they're doing before
and they're seeing the value was there
their own payer so when we go to payers
who are also integrated systems payer
and provider they get it you know they
get where we're coming yet they're not
comparing it we're dealing with the
legacy fee-for-service system and one of
the unfortunate things even though I'm a
physician is that every physician we
talked to just probably same emotions
case this is a better technology I see
the value I see your data you have
10,000 patients I get it but I have this
equipment it's a worse test but I'm
going to pay for it because the more I
do of them I got to pay for my small
business that's the reality they have
everything's fighting that ever
buddy agrees is broken and you know and
I think one thing other mentioned that
you have to understand a lot of
practices are being bought by hospitals
that's because I think physicians as a
whole are saying you know I went into
medicine to see patients not to run a
business and that's increasingly what
running a business is a practicing
physician so they'd rather be salaried
focus on the patient let someone else
handle all the admin get the you know
economies of scale of a big organization
but that's an important thing to think
about as you're thinking about your
ideas because even the type of coding
going from CPT's to a PC codes too
impatient to DRG stays depending on how
practices merge or get acquired are also
things you have to think about so I
think everyone approaches reimbursement
there's no way to know it until you
really get into it and you realize what
a marasmus so hybrid model you know
running trying to keep the electricity
on with with current sales but trying to
penetrate these these are yeah you don't
target higher value customers receptive
value use them to bring the heard okay
good they're near yeah I may put that a
different type of hybrid model so and
obviously obesity is is incredibly a
very consumer driven space I was I was
very surprised to hear the statistic
that prior to the recession a third of
patients were getting the lat man like
gastric banding for morbid obesity we're
actually paying out of their own pocket
and so another model that may be a way
of you know doing a hybrid approach and
getting through the you know valley of
reimbursement is is turning to consumers
and when when the technology lends
itself to that as one approach and and
frankly you know we the FDA is probably
our bigger hurdle even before we get to
reimbursement and you know it looking to
Europe looking to other geographies as a
good launch launch point I know most
obesity companies that are starting to
bring their products online are actually
going to the unite the UK and it's like
well like almost no medical devices
typically start you know out going up
against the in the UK healthcare system
where there is a lot of cost effective
this measures but there's a real private
pay system there and there's a patient a
consumer willingness to pay so there may
be a you know an option for technologies
that you know even when they have large
regulatory hurdles and there's
reimbursement afterwards - you know
target consumers as a way of getting up
the curve and getting through that that
value of reimbursed suit so we'll go
back to Europe and global in a little
bit but let me ask you specifically is
it part of your strategy are you in any
way practically speaking looking at
existing a cos or you know how fast is
this going to happen and what piece of
your strategy is that so being a
start-up of our size it's all about
focus and ahead right now you know
that's so that's beyond the regulatory
that's beyond no European where and it's
in a such a state of flux at this point
that by the time you know it'll be you
know three four years to over there
we're the only thing we're sure about is
that the landscapes going to look
completely different than it doesn't
have so we're going to give that a
little time to cook and then and then
wait wait to strategize once it's more
solid okay well that's clear mo I'm
going to skip you for a sec and ask
other Darren so what are you seeing as
successful early stage models with with
these issues that we're talking about
and and you have anybody coming to you
I'm kind of fixated on this you know
transition to a CEO and and whether
you're seeing anything like that I've I
think nobody's really doing that right
now at least and I wonder if you see
anything that we haven't we haven't seen
anything from oh you like so he should
probably answer that part what we are
seeing though is companies with
commercialization plans elsewhere first
and we've seen more that aren't in
Europe first we've seen more that are
Asia first in fact we just spent two or
so weeks in China and on the other
Darren's consumer pay point that's how
they're paying for their health care
especially a lap band type or obesity
type procedure right now and there are
many many millions of willing payers out
there so we're seeing stuff from that
angle not really from they feeling I'm
gonna hold you for one more minute mo
and ask is there anybody in the audience
that's with a start-up or other entity
where you you have a strategy a
proactive strategy of saying look health
care reform is coming it's going to look
like these a CE OS and and we are
actively planning for that and this is
what we're doing anybody mo so well
personal what is an ACO I don't think
I've heard it clearance by definition we
have a ce o--'s already integrated
healthcare systems it's just the thesis
around
why didn't we provide quality outcomes
let's link product solutions
interventions to cost and quality
outcomes versus the old aid adage of
medical devices which is a stripe volume
let's have high margin let's ring up DC
for a code and we're okay let's just
mean the system would I bet my 30-year
career on that thesis no way but the
people I've seen more interested in the
ACO model unfortunate from the medical
device world is more from the healthcare
IT and services well because again to
enable many of these a cos it's really
about data so how do we understand
decompensation of disease before
patients feel sick Symantec how do we
which the wireless health world is
pushing forward how do we better
coordinate care how do we give
technology to care coordinators to
improve those outcomes at a fraction of
the cost that's what we're seeing in the
landscape well what's an example or two
of that so again I again talking to the
entrepreneurs in the audience I I think
it's gonna be hard to bet everything on
an ACO I've knowing what an ACO is so
let's start earlier and go for some of
the binary changes so at the end of the
year
30-day readmission rules for CHF
pneumonia and MI are going to change if
that patient comes back within a 30-day
period the hospital will not be paid
again
in a classic fee-for-service system they
did so it was actually good for that
patient to keep on coming back again
shows how fascinating the reimbursement
system is the incentives are so
misaligned so we've seen a lot of
activity around that rule change and
hospitals getting very interested in
solutions that solve that particular
problem as time goes on you have bundle
payments for other conditions the ACO I
can predict what I think could happen
when it does kick off but I believe the
biggest change will be the distribution
channel that these guys are going to
have to go through again the the thesis
of I'm going to sell to a physician and
show him or her good data and they're
going to make a lot of money off that
device I think those days are also going
to go
sorry physicians are higher in number as
what they said the ACO s are going to be
more centralized in purchasing so
essentially what Kaiser we're doing
already so I think the biggest flux out
of this will be the channel to sell
stuff and the mechanism there one has to
do that yeah stuff about the ACO
modeling can pick up on what you said
about data and use a rhythm as an
example so you know if any of you feel
light-headed or dizzy and you go to
Stanford an emergency room they'll put
on our patch they'll put it on you if
they can't figure out what's going on
you'll go home and that's an emergency
room physician taking care of a
potential disease state possibly do it's
an abnormal heart rhythm you go home go
about your business maybe you have your
whatever you had on day 7 or 10 or
whatever you it gets recorded you mail
this back to us we process a report that
report goes back to Stanford's
cardiologists who are reading these
reports on a day to day rotation they'll
look at it they'll see that you had your
symptom they see that you had an
abnormal heart rhythm they'll call you
and say okay now it's a different
physician managing information that
started with a different physician at
the beginning they'll look at that and
say okay you need to come visit us
they'll come see you and say this is
treatable
come see an electrophysiologist like me
and you'll get treated once you see me
and you get treated I might put another
one of these dogs to see if what I did
actually have the desired effect
that's an ACO with what we do in the
sense that we're managing a disease
state enabling by a device that's really
central or centralized around
information movement and management I
mean I almost think of our company is
really an IT company enabled my med tech
device every one of these things over 14
days collects a million heartbeats and I
know every
1/2 million heartbeats I know which
physician prescribed it I know what they
find so there's a lot of business
intelligence but again I think it's the
idea of leveraging information which is
really not expensive versus leveraging
things and moving patients which is
expensive is where things are going so
in a high level that's kind of what I
pitch and they everyone gets it because
that's much more rational now we'll just
see how it gets implemented yeah can I
add one more to that sometime really
well so the classic device experience I
had was here's a product and we will
sell it that that is changing as a day
said it's more of a technology or
service with a device it's again linked
to specific outcomes that you're trying
to achieve and that's the big shift that
I see
so whose company is a good example of
this can eat can you brainstorm mo
you're seeing these give us I mean
there's got to be a wider zone than just
Wireless you know parameters of you know
heart beat digestion breathing you know
it so we can see those but where else
are we going so the way that we're
defining the universe so devices are
just the mechanism to capture data but
that that by itself is nothing apart
from if you can really capture novel
data so if you can pick up the
conversation of CHF two years in advance
which no one can do great but but in in
necessity actually most device is more
simple then that means you have to think
about how that data transmitted so
that's the wireless world how is data
stored all the analytics that you apply
data to get information that's the
healthcare IT world then how do you
present that information at the right
time to the right person in the user
interface and that's that's a
convergence of three four different
industries which which no one's really
figured out yet so there's some early
players who are essentially making their
competence around data I fundamentally
there's at Google to be built within
healthcare who can really understand
this data coming from multi source
whether it's genomics devices clinical
data and then really turn it into
something meaningful and if you push me
to where I think the biggest opportunity
is post healthcare reform I was talking
to Daren about this providers are now at
risk and I've heard of the grapevine
some payers actually want to get out of
the the classic insurance business they
want to be reinsurance to the ACO mod
who will be at risk and I think that's a
really interesting concept and you can
see that all in the landscape my caveat
is this is all timing how long will it
take for this to settle down and I think
it's more years rather than two they're
months which which makes it very
difficult as an entrepreneur in terms of
your business model what do you want to
build your company for but um I'll go
back to the basic fundamentals that the
statistics around health care spend are
terrible as you know 2065 will spend a
hundred percent of GDP on health care
that's not going to happen and things
will fail way before then so if we
really focus on product solutions that
can help reduce the cost which will get
remunerate ydynt una business models
emerging I think that's a good better
place so I smell a contrarian situation
here which which is you know every time
I hear value-based innovation talked
about it has to do with the interface
with information technology and and it's
just the classic example your the
classic example and then you see
something like artyom right so ardian is
anybody familiar enough for the already
in to tell the story
Darrin - do you know that one well
enough for I won't pick on okay so so
the basically this is a local company
that just sold very attractively to
Medtronic that came up with a
catheter-based solution for hypertension
and it's kind of based on some classic
physiologic studies that that were done
years ago where surgeons would would
actually cut the nerves that go to the
kidney kidney as he knows involved in
regulating blood pressure so as a
last-ditch procedure if you if you cut
those nerves you could drop the blood
pressure company the foundry local
incubator picked up on that developed a
catheter-based strategy for doing this
and the cost implications of that are
absolutely phenomenal right so they have
three year good data on on reducing
blood pressure and and so
the contrarian play that I was talking
about is that I absolutely feel it in my
water that there are great technology
simple technologies that have not been
invented that are cost saving and Darren
you may have one of those right so but I
think it thinking about different ways I
mean you know we talked about it I mean
one of the things I think at the
government level is that and goes back
to my comment about payers we were what
I gave and what there and what Moe and I
were talking about maybe have to do with
Diagnostics
particularly information management so
again if you're thinking about an ACL
model in terms of outcomes I break
things down to four big buckets you know
you have an acute diagnostic that is
changing you can change like what I do
you know changing when something is
diagnosed if it obviates multiple tests
multiple visits repeat tests to get to
the same outcome that's call safe know
you can have acute therapies so it's
like an RDA you have a one-time therapy
but to really value its outcome you have
to look across the disease state of the
patient which means not only treating
them now what did it prevent but also
treating them now what it increased in
terms of their productivity in terms of
you know their ability to work not be on
time etc then on the you know a chronic
you have like things chronic
therapeutics taking a pill every day
getting dialysis three times a week you
have to look at what are the outcome
effects on the disease state to get to
the outcome model and then there's you
know well we talked about chronic
therapy those are the kind of the
buckets that you can think about you
know acute chronic but you know sorry
acute point in time chronic point in
time we're like putting in a
defibrillator one-time shot people say
it's very expensive but we know that
we're agree as a US and Stephanus will
tell us this that we agree to $50,000 a
year for dialysis to get quality of life
years going forward defibrillators
twenty or thirty thousand saves lives
but how is that measuring yeah on an
annual budget cycle it's not a
worthwhile thing but over the course of
several years it is so and I think
guidelines support that ACC doesn't
recommend putting in someone happier to
live so I do think their outcomes that
are not information only that tie to
outcomes based a cos it's just that we
have to define them better particularly
with technology
yeah good we had a question in the front
and
I got blinded by the light I'm sorry
about that
I'm shubra I'm a physician from Indiana
student at Stanford so this is for the
physicians out there just in terms of
the opportunity cost how valuable would
you say has the advanced medical
training beyond just the four years of
med school being in the industry in
terms of giving you a leverage they'll
start some people thought was useless
and then and then some I think it really
depends on fit so if someone's looking
for a clinical person they'll find you
but the hardest transition I found an
issue was being a clinical person then
trying to enter into the business role
again because of supply demand
preconceptions and again that was in the
classic med tech world and then soon as
I just serendipitously
steps sort of sideways to an industry
which was growing and evolving didn't
have a huge amount of supply physicians
I got a lot more traction I can say that
I mean I think for me I took a year off
after med school to see if I really like
device to them and I realized that at
the end of the day going to med school
you you learn something taking care of
people and coding them at five in the
morning and no one else is around in a
18 bed CCU that's being a physician so
there are two different things and I
think if you really want to understand
unmet medical needs in your field and
you want to be focused more on the
understanding the needs figuring out how
to solve those problems it is helpful
the flip side of that is it's a long
road and you know and again being able
to practice and do all these things is a
balancing act but I think it really
depends as most said the right fit I
mean if you're really going to
transition more to the business side
maybe it's not as important but if you
really want to be more on the clinical
insight and understand from and again
you know what we talked a lot about is
the design experience I mean we've tried
to do a lot with the user experience for
the patient the physician but I know
that because I've been there not I'm on
the physician side but it's really
really important to understand and
empathize with those things because
that's where you see some of those
insights and unless you've been there
quite a few times it's sometimes hard so
I don't think there's a right answer I
really think about are you going to
build more business-oriented or more
perhaps stay a little bit more medically
focused and keep doing the
clinical invention side I'll give that
I'll give that one a shot to because I
was in medical school and left is the
smallest one of us yeah so I think it
just really comes down to if you like
being in medical school stay in medical
school I mean honestly God that and if
if you're spending those at the years
that you're spending in medical school
and you're probably paying a lot of
money and you're working really really
hard and you're in the library by
yourself with a book you know at 2:00 in
the morning if if that's driving you
that's driving you and you want to take
care of patients stay in medical school
if you don't if you don't we should talk
more afterwards but if you don't do you
need it I don't think you need know an
MD I don't think you need it it helps
you get called a doctor you get respect
you've earned the respect you don't need
it but it depends on you gotta like what
you're doing at that time so from the
perspective of if you want to help the
patients by inventing new devices
wouldwould so targeted more towards
probably more and doctor they would you
do it again oh yeah definitely I mean I
think it's not I I think it's like I
would say less about inventing devices
but really understanding where the needs
of healthcare are I mean unless you like
I said taking care of patients
understood all the craziness that
happens when you're in a hospital or in
a clinic or seeing patients come from
far away with their loved ones or having
to give someone bad news that's where
you see needs you don't have to be a
physician but you can see needs from a
physician perspective you can still see
needs in a very important way if you're
not a physician no question from a
business perspective an engineering
perspective but again in trying to
understand what do you like doing at the
end of the day I mean you know when
you're in your late 20s early 30s you
have narrowed down somewhat to what fits
with your personality and what you like
doing the world is not always it's like
the art of choosing that we heard of
this morning and you have to make a
choice
thank you so I heard a statistic earlier
this week that they're about a hundred
medical students at Stanford and 27 have
want business degrees so I I think that
maybe a referendum on health care reform
I'm not sure but
I think that this the the question of
like what do we really want to do with
our lives you know it's it's one for all
of us and you know there's a lot of talk
amongst my colleagues here about you
know why are you spending your life
doing a class-3 PMA device a product I
mean this is something that doesn't fly
around in the air and you know when it
comes down to it this is you know a
medical need that I thought was
incredibly worthwhile
I had veterans in the industry that had
you know worked at obesey startups
telling me don't do it they're like
you're gonna you may waste five years
you may waste a decade of your life
because that's that was the feeling that
they had you know working as their
companies and at the end of the day you
know I you look out there you're like
there are 20 million Americans and I'm
looking at the rest of the world just
Americans they're eligible for bariatric
surgery for these weight loss procedures
and less than 2% of them actually get it
and you talked to the patients that are
making these you know gut-wrenching
decisions about do they really want to
go to the knife do they not like was it
going to mean for their families like
this is this is really an area that
needs to be changed and it's worth it's
worth while thankfully I was able to
convince some investors it was also
worthwhile and it's going to be helping
patients now because ekaadasha nough
bout what you're talking about in
healthcare I wouldn't do it it's pretty
timely now our friends from Facebook all
retiring and buying lots in New York and
healthcare is so fragmented and
regulated that you're not gonna get
those same type of opportunities
compared to tech you really have to be
passionate about this space which I
think we all like I think one of the
things that I would ask there and I
think none of us would disagree with is
that the end of the day if none of our
companies have seed I wouldn't have
traded the experience for anything in
terms of what I've learned and I think
that's really important you really have
to go into it thinking about what am I
going to learn from the
you can give yourself some reasonable
time limits I mean don't say I'm going
to do this for 20 years and well I mean
but really focus and say like if I can
when I started the company I gave myself
six to twelve months to get funded if I
couldn't get funded maybe it wasn't the
right time but you really have to set
limits but if you do and you keep going
and going and you're seeing progress at
the end of the day that's invaluable
so you know and from a company
standpoint experience means more than
anything in terms of who we hire yes my
name is Edith engineering here and I
also have another career related
question at Stanford it's so
entrepreneurial it seems like there's
this baseline assumption of of course
everyone wants to start a company we
call it Google itis yeah exactly but you
know starting a company versus maybe
tackling some of those problems that
you're passionate about as employee
number 10 or as part of a large
organization very different situations
and a lot of trade-offs and I was
wondering if you could talk about the
decision process to decide you know to
do what I want to do I have to start a
company and how you weighed some of
those trade-offs for your personal
situation somebody one leave yeah I snow
I started my career at Medtronic not a
small company by any stretch of the
imagination and I found it was it was a
fantastic environment and even even
though I was in you know a thirty
thousand person organization
I found myself gravitating towards you
know looking at challenging problems
that I thought just need to be solved so
ended up doing intrapreneurship inside
my track which was a wonderful place to
start because here you have all this
infrastructure all this money and all
these incredible people that can help
you bring bring something to fruition so
it's but there's a there's a pros and
cons to that you know at the time I was
you know twenty two years old trying to
work inside of a very large bureaucracy
and getting buy-in you know from the
president of the organization that yeah
you should give me six million dollars
and fifty people to help you know bring
this new product to market and that
process you know to six to nine months
it wasn't unlike actually fundraising
yeah so now there is there and so that
was you know brought the product to
market it was great it was a fantastic
opportunity but what I learned from that
intrapreneurial experience is well
there's a lot you know what would it be
like to do the Entrepreneurship
experience and you know the value I
remember we spent a quarter million
dollars on five lines of code because
there were some programmers
and Lafayette were the only people that
could do this in the world and then I
look at what I did with the first
quarter million dollars at hourglass and
you know it's it's night and day you
know we kind of started proving in some
preclinical models that like this could
this could be a brand new therapy for
patients so there is it's the large
companies definitely provide a great
great learning experience but there's
nothing quite like starting something
from scratch and and something that's
the world's never seen before
we should also underestimate all of this
is there's a huge element of luck I mean
you know you can it's a lot of being in
the right place at the right time so I
think it's more about creating the
opportunities for UB to be in the right
place at the right time it goes back to
what I was saying earlier everyone can
be an entrepreneur but doesn't mean and
there's a lot of really good ideas but
there's not as many successful companies
and a lot of that has to do with things
which are outside of your control so I
think it's more about getting the right
experience that makes you passionate
about whatever you're doing and
hopefully that'll lead to providing the
opportunities and experiences that will
then afford a higher likelihood of
getting that entrepreneurial experience
if that's what you seek so let's shift
gears did you have a comment up just one
quick thing on that is I you're always
better off when you surround yourself
with good people people who care about
you people who have done whether you're
starting your own company and they're
advising you or whether you're in a big
company and working for somebody as long
as they know you're there care about you
and want to help you you're always going
to be better off I think so I want to
move to talking about global strategies
I'm going to ask you each to think about
what you've done in your in your with
your own businesses
and I want to invite people in the
audience too we have some experienced
folks and you know you know if you if
you want to contribute discussion please
do but let me start mo I actually don't
know what you would say about about
Global Strategy so let's start with you
so what we actually have a part of that
we're about to spit out I'll give you
our pieces first so you may have heard
some of the other speakers this morning
but they're actually more mobile phones
in the world and shoes and people have
access to phones easier than clean water
countries in Africa and India are
building their healthcare systems from
the ground up without ever gonna have
the number of physicians that we have
here all these technologies so it's an
interesting place to see what's going on
and something that we want to capitalize
on so I think the thesis of high volume
low margin devices and solutions versus
what we see here in the u.s. is is a
real opportunity so we have a low cost
maternal health solution that were still
prototyping and then at some point that
will be spun out is going live in Mexico
first and then India and Brazil and
essentially it's not rocket science it's
very simple frugal innovation the gold
standard right now in a hospital is a
cardio toka gram between five to ten
thousand dollars we have a couple of
hundred dollars version which is
Bluetooth enabled you don't need a
physician at the point of care a nurse
can carry that around the data goes to a
centralized place and we're bundling
that with blood proof and blood glucose
blood pressure and your own dipstick so
again not rocket science stuff but will
have a huge impact in maternal health
and mortality we hope Darrin height so
companies coming to you what what
percentage have a Europe only strategy
and and how are you assessing that none
have a Europe only strategy we did a
thing recently where we looked at the
companies were we've currently invested
in and every one of them on the device
side was somewhere else in the world
other than the United States either
selling or manufacturing or testing or
every single one was somewhere I think
that we've actually looked at some of
the things that mo is talking about I
don't know we're good at knowing what's
good there yet but we're focusing there
because of
constraint here that these guys know way
better than I do but yeah I think I
think every company should be thinking
that way but we're not seeing it every
company can sometimes we see a guy like
Darren with a good idea and that's okay
for the time being so you have companies
coming to you with medical devices that
that are saying we're doing 510k we're
doing PMA in the US and just kind of a
standard yeah yeah okay and if it's and
and like you said earlier there's still
some really good things to be created in
the good old fashioned medical device
industry - are you funding them yeah we
actually record it so PMA devices go to
other deaf inches in town Darren so
you're you're both your strategy if you
can tell us and your perspective yeah so
I look at this no different than I look
at funding for the company because this
is just crime the next level funding for
the company and you know creativity is
going to need to be involved for devices
that are class 3 p.m. a devices because
the FDA is not an easy place to get
through nowadays so I'm really focusing
the company outside the United States
and saying you know we need to be able
to build it pays
in both business in Europe and in other
geographies and you know well we'll wait
to see what's going to be happening with
the FDA but I'm not going to bet the
entire company on that it's just too
uncertain so well we like a lot of the
opportunities outside and so we're we're
going to be securing up for that kind of
structure and at a personal level it
kills me because I really you know there
are a lot of patients I need I needs on
planes I'm you know I go out and
actively interview and this is a therapy
that I'm really excited to bring to
patients here you know in our own
country and it's gonna be a long time so
are you talking about Europe really
practically speaking you mean that
that's where you'll get traction yeah
you know Europe Australia there and
these are just areas that unfortunately
obesity is a global epidemic you know
there so we can go almost almost
anywhere but there like Darren saying
there are some very interesting
countries like China and India where
there's a consumer more of a consumer
pay event and that's a great that's a
great start what are you expecting to
run into as a difficulty as you actually
what what what's your white hot risk
with that strategy people people so it's
just getting the right people aligned
around to the table that and on one side
are not myopically focused on the US and
really look at the other geographies not
as owe us but like as you know this is
this can be the main entree so our
biggest risk there is going to be really
finding the right recruiting the right
people to help us deliver on that
strategy but as far as our the patients
there is there is their money there
that's that's not the issue for us to
what extent are you influenced so a
common thing we hear is be the big
strategic the big companies have all
this offshore money that they don't want
to repatriate so great exit strategy to
come up in Europe and
is that discussed around your boardroom
we're not so we're not too worried about
repatriating money yet because we just
want to make money but that I mean let's
be let's be real ardian was a stunning
success and we would love to you know
follow that model of showing something
that has tremendous clinical value in
patients and then working with a large
strategic to help make that a standard
of care then that was kind of what I
would learn in my time at Medtronic you
know there weren't there were a lot of
other innovative things happening out of
belsen elsewhere in the medical world
but you know Medtronic was fantastic at
distribution and truly making things a
standard of care and a big success for
our glass is ensuring that our device
gets to as many patients as possible and
so we'll go through with whatever
channels are necessary to achieve that
okay your strategy yeah are just a
little different in a different way
because we didn't have as much
regulatory risk as a 510k
we were focused on the u.s. from the
beginning we talked a little bit about
the reimbursement which is a moderate
risk but I think the other thing we
wanted to think about is our device in
our approach is very very low cost and
we want to keep driving that cost lower
so I think the biggest opportunity for
us are in the BrickCon in India in China
eventually eventually but you know I
think we can drive the cost of this
product in our service even lower with
volume so as we get volume in the US
that can help us drive manufacturing
cost cogs down we can then go to Health
Canada we can go to NHS and say as a
system we can provide this device far
lower cost than anything you have right
now because we've already we will have
been able to you know deliver the cost
reductions because of the volume we're
seeing in the US the other thing is from
a strategic standpoint at the end of the
day I'm electrophysiologist so I want to
treat people who have arrhythmias
because we can treat them big companies
like Medtronic st. Jude st. Jude's an
investor in our company you know Boston
Scientific they make products very
expensive products but very efficacious
products for people have certain
arrhythmias emerging markets are big
for them now so at the end of the day
it's very difficult to penetrate India
with a ten thousand twenty thousand
dollar defibrillator and and price it
lower to get into the market or do what
you have to but to get a device that's
fifty hundred dollars or whatever it
might be broadly to diagnose people who
otherwise may you know be left
undiagnosed with vague symptoms much
easier value proposition to then
convince some of them that look you have
this big huge pause where you don't have
a heartbeat for six seconds maybe you do
need a pacemaker and with a device that
they were able to buy and like I'll do
it that's a selling point so I think our
strategy is more from a strategic sales
strategy in the use of the gold market I
definitely think there's a bigger market
for our product elsewhere but right now
the US will prove it out for us to go
hole us and again one of the things
personal important reason we continue to
export I don't want to import what's
what's your protection and India and
China so we have well we haven't you
know from our PCT applications and we
started you know we've gone into Canada
EU Japan but not much in China biz
they're really it's it's still a Wild
West so I think we'll eventually get
there but we'll keep moving east your
until we get there hopefully we'll learn
hopefully some of the things we've seen
on the Stanford Indian side some of the
more regular regulations and protections
will be in place years from now and at
the end of the day you know finding more
arrhythmias if it floats everybody's
both in terms of devices they have
almost no penetration there so they're
starting from scratch with a
unpenetrated population of billion plus
so I don't know if that's gonna be too
much of memory most of your fist man on
the panel I'm gonna ask you about your
global strategy to if you would but I
also want to ask anybody else in the
audience who is primarily focusing on a
developing nation strategy
anybody with commute can you tell us
about that quickly there's a mic right
next to you that would be great
my name is Peter quell on a rural family
physician I developed a smart system for
the neonatal space that actually mo kind
of mirrors your product where we're
going for a low cost
the barriers here in the US were just
formidable we were trying to push a
device for risk reduction in lowering
cost and we just don't find that VCS
were open to that yet so India's seems
to be a place with open arms and it's a
you know a low-cost you know a very
different market strategy than the US we
you know our you know cost point would
be twenty thousand dollars here we're
gonna be trying to bring it in to
developing countries for eight hundred
and using a three-tier market where you
get it out to the poor for free and some
of your tertiary care hospitals you have
a premium price a multi tiered marketing
strategy and are you NGO funded is it is
it for profit what's your mom what's my
my the business model I'm still very
word early startup we have our working
prototype and we'll be pitching four
different foundations here soon towards
July me good luck
other people who've done developing yeah
please so I'm not with a small company
Verna Rodriguez with Boston Scientific
hi heard of that yes so Boston
Scientific is has an emerging market
initiative so from a large company
perspective with all the changing
healthcare and Boston Scientific
historically being very myopically us
focused I think is waking up and saying
oh we need to sort of change what we
want to do in the world in terms of
selling products and not be so us
focused so we're doing things like we
already have some manufacturing in
countries like Ireland and also Costa
Rica and we're expanding more in Costa
Rica but also we've started we have a
small group of folks in China that's a
Boston Scientific based company and so
we're looking not only to enter those
markets by actually manufacturing in in
countries to reduce cost but also to be
able to have a presence in those markets
so that we can invent and innovate
devices that are for those markets not
with the US focused so that's what
Boston Scientific is doing so that's why
I'm here
yeah thank you you know stunning I heard
John kapex remarks this morning about
that the market shifts that they're
anticipating in in five years time just
extraordinary
so Moshe tell us about your strategy so
we mainly looked at the diversifying
reimbursement risk and before going
global one one can think first
creatively about alternative US pair so
one one system which we like is the the
VA Medical system that the dispense is
about seventy billion dollars of
healthcare spent each year it's a
relatively more straightforward process
to get on the federal supply schedule
and that's a way to basically the
diversify or mitigate a bit of the
reimbursement risk and something that we
have implemented quite quite effectively
beyond the VA Medical system with a bit
of product like like ours one may start
thinking creatively about FEMA and all
of those disaster relief organizations
you know they're stalking or you want to
tell us about your product is quick
because a product is basically a
single-use and negative pressure wound
therapy device for for the treatment of
chronic of chronic wounds and it can
help treat acute wounds as well once
hemostasis has been has been achieved
negative pressure wound therapy which is
the application of controlled
suction to wounds through an interface
of former Gaza interface is the
eighth-largest
DME category that and medicare spend in
the u.s. the product sales are about 1.5
billion
it's been the carry the category has
grown 600 percent over five years in
terms of Medicare payment and my
frustration is even that we brought him
a product I can just eliminate half of
this costs just out of the out of the
box that wasn't that wasn't a sufficient
but it's a therapy that basically is
broad application to a lot of soft
tissue defects and our experience in in
the aftermath of the earthquake in Haiti
which we sent our one of our co-founders
a clinician with a lot of products as a
part of the initiative of the University
of Miami we've seen that we were able to
very effectively help folks in the
aftermath of an earthquake especially
when there are blackouts and no
electricity and all the electrical
capital equipment type devices just
weren't able to be effective and they
were treating a folks at hospital things
so that kind of brought us the idea well
gee we could we should be approaching a
FEMA and approaching and approaching a
DoD more to understand what at a
criteria so that they would stock such a
product is part of a relief or or
disaster after that could be you know
one stalking order could be are probably
revenue projections for for next year
another one is of course the VA medical
system in terms of us we are
implementing those very very
aggressively so one of the methods we
used to stay capital efficient in in the
you in in our operations and be able to
penetrate markets quickly is to really
seek partners that would help us
penetrate for example the European
market and and that also ties a bit to
our to our exit strategy it's kind of
let's that's dance before we before we
get get married can a kind of thing so
there is some strategic rationale with
the with the choice of distributor we go
we go with in the in the EU and beyond
of that we've launched a regulatory
process in
Japan we also through a partner that
that invested in us but I think that all
these or us commercialization in
endeavors need to build on an honor and
a bedrock of FDA clearance for example
in the in Europe what's left after that
is the I so certain a fairly
straightforward process to get clearance
if you don't have FDA clearance in the
US it's a different story same holds for
Japan although the processes in the FTA
that way was our FDA pathway was not a
510 K was a de novo process so we took
care about 18 months something that Todd
would take less than answer so there's
maybe an irritating question but but it
seems to me you must be worried about
people re-engineering your device
especially in Asia do you have a
strategy about that yeah so yeah we are
strategy may sound funny to you guys
he's got his part again a partner who's
daddy's really senior in the in the
Communist Party and so nobody would
nobody would coffee or a vice that we're
working on is really so we have a
program here's my chance to identify
guys for well intertwined indie and the
political apparatus and and those are
usually the joint ventures in the
collaborations that end up with their IP
rights they're protected
so that's really our strategy by by the
way we have submitted national phase
applications moves in China and Japan
but I'm just looking at the data and
till it until early this year there
hasn't been a single foreigner foreign
company that is one a case a case trial
case in in Japan irrespective of the
rights and the contracts that were
signed so we're doing that but it's not
something that I but you haven't seen
devices emerging yet that are compared
we haven't seen devices that emerging
yet at are there are competitive we have
seen interesting ideas coming from from
academia and from students working in
Agartha that's that's okay area of
concern
good thanks so so mo you have a clear
developing world strategy I mean that
that and and that makes great sense for
Aaron for you know that the high-end
medical devices is there a development
world strategy or is that even on your
radar screen it to be honest it really
isn't as much on our radar screen well I
guess I should ask which geographies
you're just riff on it whatever whatever
you want to say it's hard to even think
about you know whether Brazil and China
and India are developing or whether
they're way ahead of the United States
at this point so depending how you how
you look at it but advanced developing
nation yeah but ya know I mean I was
just talking to some surgeons in Brazil
this this past weekend at a at a large
medical conference and you know I look
at the infrastructure they have down
there it's it's really exciting like our
technology would dovetail beautifully
into that because at the heart of it
even what we're doing is we're taking a
very invasive technology and making it
you know basically a conscious sedation
outpatient procedure it's moving from
expensive or to a very much less
expensive endoscopy suite and that's a
model that could work very well in in
regions where you know capital costs
could be a huge barrier to offer
procedures for patients so you know we
definitely see there's there's plenty of
opportunity there and a lot of you know
the it's incredible actually how much
the procedure volumes were were growing
in Brazil that's that's a market we're
gonna be monitoring very closely so
we're going to get in just a minute to
kind of asking you guys to look around
the corner and again I'd welcome any
questions about that from the audience
but but sort of to prime the pump for
that one thing that that I'm hearing a
lot anyway from from young innovators
young companies is that really the name
of the game now is to figure out what
the strategics want to do right away if
possible have that discussion
and and get funding you know at a seed
stage or series a what are what do
you've seen and what do you think about
that maybe I'll start with Fahrenheit
again on that what's tricky so what so
the idea being that you need to know
because it's so tough now to go through
the series
you know ABCD but that you really need a
partnership worked out with a strategic
early on and the best thing to do is to
really start right away with that that
kind of partnership discussion yeah I
don't know if that's the best thing to
do to start that way actually I think
the thing that the places were we've
succeeded in dealing with bigger
companies is usually to have a
technology that scares them a little bit
it takes their mind share of their key
positions or you know you can go to a
Europe let's say and have their highest
using physicians start to use your
product and then tell his friends and
then get them to start using the product
and then all of a sudden they really
want to be your partner before then
it hasn't really happened as much for us
well when you're in your world so I
don't think I'm doing anything that the
big medtechs would be interested in
because a model so different I'm
actually getting more interested from
the strategic like Intel Cisco how about
you do
I mean this has been our model we worse
we were in a garage when Johnson Johnson
invested in us I don't know if they knew
were in a garage at the time but yeah it
you know looking at the capital
requirements for a class three device
and you know I wanted to make sure that
there would be a tremendous amount of
alignment and what and I know that there
was a tremendous amount of controversy
when I talked to advisors and mentors
about do you bring a strategic in early
and where the pros and cons there and do
they put handcuffs on you and and you
know it's all how you structure a deal
you can make it so that it works great
for the company and Johnson Johnson has
been a tremendous partner and has been
extremely helpful so if you know I were
to do it all
again I would certainly jump into bed
early with a strategic I think they
provide profound insights on you know
what the market is doing right now and
then does that look like what's your
actual interface with with the company I
mean what kinds of people are helping
you and so we also have a strategic
relationship with obviously Johnson
Johnson is a very large company at the
Khan endo surgery is the segment that
focuses on bariatric surgery as well as
all you know surgical type devices and
you know we it gives us the ability to
interface with experts from
reimbursement clinical regulatory
marketing you know it really brings a
tremendous amount of resources to bear
that frankly we could never afford as a
start-up company today you have a
relationship with st. Jude yeah so st.
Jude invested in us that our be round
after we had clearance and we're really
starting to market our product and and I
think that's more typical they want to
see a little bit later stage where
there's gonna perhaps be an impact that
some of the regulatory were other risks
and taken off the table while I think
all the big companies and critiques are
all thinking they'd like to invest
earlier I think the reality is that you
know you might be exception but it
doesn't really happen because it still
did two different from their DNA at the
moment so I don't know how much how
often that's happened the other thing I
would say is when you do make a deal
with the rity Jake if you have multiple
potential strategic exit partners
there's a downstairs a plus and minus of
having one of those as your partner so
our deal leaves the back end open you
know there's no it's just an investment
they're an investor and we have a
co-marketing relationship so they help
market our products but that's where it
ends so I do think it's very important
to leave to make sure that when you
structure those deals if possible you
think about the pros and cons of what
that means downstream is that they're
getting everything they want from you
and you're locked in to them that could
be a tough situation for you whereas if
you're not that could be actually to
your advantage yeah so we have seen some
deals with people trying to lock up our
companies you know we'll invest early
but if you're ever anything
we own you and that's a bad position to
be for sure anybody with experience in
the audience with are you in companies
that have a close strategic partner
anybody here a few the venture people
are seeing these I'm sure at this point
but but many any comment about this from
your standpoint so if you don't know
meadow Meadows one of the very
experienced serial CEOs in medtech in
the valley thanks Paul I think that
everything there is no general rules and
as we conceived him the panel here
the gentleman has a terrific
relationship with J&J I'm sure he put
together a deal that he can get out of
it and actually will be more attractive
to a potential other buyer knowing that
J&J has interesting his deal so there
are no rules and I think that we need to
be very open to learn and find out where
the opportunities are whether we're
doing a global deal well maybe the best
opportunities in the u.s. what are you
trying to accomplish they're trying to
prove the product works well can you
prove it maybe you don't have to go
through if they approve maybe you can do
basically an fvm if I am in the US and
that will trigger a nice deal for you so
I would recommend that basically the the
market and the needs are continuously
changing it's like a pendulum we're
talking about healthcare reform where my
my big success was in 1995 when Hillary
Clinton tried to introduce health care
reform and cost was everything that
everybody talked about and I had a
product that basically I didn't even
know what it was good for to prove its
value it's clinical value and I found
out that it can cut significantly the
number of angel Plastics in the US and
happened to be that at that time health
care reform cost savings capitation was
the big buzz the cardiologist obviously
didn't like it those are my customers
but the financial community
he loved it and I was able to take the
company public but then after a year and
a half or two health care reform didn't
work then I rushed to sell all right so
let's let's bring this around yeah
please
do you mind using the mic Thanks I can
speak loud but I'll use the mic my name
is Guido nails I have a long history
with guidance and many and a few other
companies I'm not a venture capitalist
and I'm learning a lot and really happy
to hear that people are thinking now
about countries like Germany and Holland
which is the Netherlands by the way and
so you know I have a couple of things
that I really want to point out it's
nothing there's a lot of advice that you
should get we should you make up your
own minds about things first about about
dealing with large companies I think
it's in your best interest to as a CEO
to start early having conversations with
strategics and they're only about 10 and
so because you're going to learn a lot
you're gonna learn how they think and
when the moment is right then you can
you can kind of step in you're right you
should really the lots of ways of
structuring this and so I don't think it
hurts to to speak with them and even to
get an investment because all the large
companies have now stepped in where VCS
have stepped out and so they are
actually very attractive very attractive
potential investors because they are
taking more risks because in the balance
sheet it does all in the profit and the
P&L it doesn't mean a hell of a lot and
particularly where they are talking
about the white spaces I think it can be
really interesting but also they large
companies are doing two things they want
to feed their distribution system or
they want to fill the white spaces and I
saw you got to kind of understand where
are you going to fit and while I have
the microphone Paul
please I you know Europe doesn't exist
in health care you should really
understand it very well every country
you can only get a CT mark and that's
just about it
and the problem is your boards don't
understand most of your boards don't
understand that either and there's a lot
of you know there's a lot of talk about
this but every country once you have a
see e mark every country will want more
clinical data will particularly want
what is called now health technology
assessments so they will want to
establish in their particular country if
this is of value in Europe we have the
the system has thought about value and
cost of the system you know doctors get
educated in thinking about the costs
when when they prescribe when they
prescribe the therapy so every country
is if every country is different on how
they reimburse the system some countries
don't really have a reimbursement system
but they have hospital budgets so my
point is you want to really focus on one
or two countries and go deep in a few
centers because you're gonna waste a
tremendous amount of money and you have
to understand while you're going outside
of those out outside of those countries
there's two reasons basically why you
want to do it is if you have a PMA you
want understand better how your how your
therapy works and adjust it as you go so
you wanna once your file for an IND then
you know you have a very high
probability that you're actually going
to be successful and you're gonna get
PMA approval and I think that's what our
lenders
did know they established very well the
therapy now we really understand this
therapy actually works and before the
company has actually an IND just like
CoreValve they now they they monetize
their investment CoreValve
existed for almost for more than 10
years and Guardian was only four years
back to your point if it's a big therapy
you know it doesn't have to
vit ball so the second thing why why you
would want to go there is basically to
prove to particularly to the large
investors or I'm sorry to the large
companies is that you actually have
adoption that people will you know
people are people meaning doctors will
prescribe you therapy and hospitals will
actually pay for it and so because then
they think all right this is something
very worthwhile I have a much bigger I
haven't I can integrate this in my in my
distribution system sorry well thank you
it's great to have experts like this and
speaking of that and this will have to
keep this short because we need to wrap
but but please yeah from an angel
perspective first I have to agree with
Dido and as a good Belgium you know
Europe is a whole bunch of different
countries they happen to be on the same
continent but from an angel point of
view anything we see that's a PMA and
all of that with Hunt
except we've made exceptions and when we
invested in is company that we can with
a small amount of capital the risk to
product and the market adoption and we
usually do that by going to Europe when
we talk to the big corporation what
they're telling us to say we want to
redo the PMA and the IDE our way anyway
because we don't think you know how to
do quality control so don't spend a lot
of money there just show me this market
adoption with a few key centers and I
will buy you up and these are the deals
are being funded they ever come and I
wanted to make is early on the global
we're having a portfolio company
companies are in India and they've great
traction and they got the government to
pass a law to say you have to do it the
problem is getting them funded for the
Sears B and C because the venture
capital is in the US and they're still
not comfortable even investing in
American corporation where the market is
overseas so that we have a problem in
scaling these models yeah good points
Thanks and this does bring us to final
thoughts and we have less than a minute
each but but let me ask you to think
about either you know if so suppose that
you all got bought out tomorrow
tremendous success what's your next
thing and what what direction what piece
of advice do you have we'll just go down
the line a succinct piece of
advice okay well I think I take a
vacation and I think what I would do
would you know I think you know the only
thing that's valuable in life is time
money can only buy time I have two
little kids I spent a lot of time with
them I spend more time though okay Aaron
well my first little ones on the way so
I'm sure I learned that lesson very
quickly consume like what what has been
really saying that hourglass and why
continue is the focus on consumers
patients as consumers and I think I'm a
shift more towards you know devices that
patients can actually just actually buy
and pay for themselves
and that when they really see the value
then I think it's a great medical device
so and I'm looking for more consumer
centric technology great and I'm a big
believer when this deep regulatory
change there's deep opportunities at the
tail end of that so I would keep a close
eye on health reform and just think of
again the fundamental statistics health
care costs are going up we're getting
more elderly people in the population
they have more chronic disease which
drives more cost and we now have less
physicians because the Stanford kids are
retiring and going to business school so
so technology and solutions can help
solve and mitigate some of those
problems so it's a good place to think
through yeah I would I would just start
by saying I think it's a really exciting
time to be doing what we're doing I
think that there's a lot of change
happening and I think a lot of good will
come out of it and a lot of opportunity
will come out of it I like the fact that
this the convergence of other industries
outside of healthcare finally getting
into healthcare that's happened in the
finance and not so much in education
that's on its way there too so I would
focus in how mobile devices the internet
IT the cloud computing can actually get
into healthcare and make meaningful
change to healthcare so I'm optimistic
well I'm sure the panelists will stick
around for a little bit after we wind up
this really brings us to the end of the
summit I see some of the organizers
in the office in the audience
congratulations on a terrific day